my ask embrace money yeah let's keep
playing poly bridge I'm so good at this
game this game is so relaxing it reminds
me of life and how we're all gonna die
one day but that's okay because it just
will just build bridges until then oh
yeah I couldn't do this one good Ike I
don't know all right all right I got it
I got it
stay tuned it's gonna be okay all right
I know you're throwing out and [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is wrong with this bridge we got
this [ __ ] in the bank you I don't have a
bag but if I kept [ __ ] in it I'd be
pretty gross but that's them what laugh
yourself bad is it I already forgot how
you played the game is this okay well
that's not how you do it
all right that's good to know fairness
[Music]
go fast my child
yes that's exactly how I wanted it to go
of cos for my back fun
next one place 12 meter drawbridge holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] when they said I couldn't
build it for me to one I thought they
were kidding
but then they weren't how does this what
I do with this look at that bridge it
fell maybe you want to quit when things
fail but you can't just fail when things
quit let's start desist that was a great
bridge you know what
sometimes when you fail you just have to
start over
try a little harder maybe look at what
you've done and say hey I can do better
than that I want to make out with that
bridge unless it was unethical for me to
make out with this bridge then I'd
totally do it
I told to make out with that bridge I
built the bridge once it was nice I'm
building a bridge right now actually yes
it's pretty terrible I'm not gonna lie
but lying will never solve anything
unless you're telling the truth and if
you are then well you're a little [ __ ]
probably this is a pretty flawless
design if I may say so myself may I say
so myself of course I mean I asked
myself so yes of course
of course let's put a cable here just
for good luck
you never know these days cables [ __ ]
hey the bridge made it after looking
things under positive side everyone's
involved the bridge made it but if I
don't make it then really what's the
point
how angled can we build these for the
card to still go I'm saying you know
exactly what I'm saying don't you okay
sorry
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] bridge and
that's okay
sometimes that bridges failed hey can't
go too steep
okay that's good to know look at this
bridge but I mean look at this bridge
Wow amazing oh god oh god oh god
[ __ ] well not everything in life is easy
if it was then Gooch it wouldn't die
right now good your head to die look at
this [ __ ] bridge boy awful [ __ ]
sake Kunta you [ __ ] [ __ ]
this place reminds me of my my first
love so innocent and pure but it just
had to fall apart look at that beautiful
concern now go home and make it love to
your wife
Dean Jeff now boys pick them up fine
buddy yeah how is it I'm shake Wow
now let's make this the best bridge that
has ever breached
[Music]
I wanted was for you to Kraus why don't
you love me back Britt I just wanted you
to craft my love ha ha ha
now cross that bridge [ __ ] you did it
we did it bros I'm proud
I pray for bridge King everyday I pray
for his return why did he leave us why
hasn't he spoken to us for a thousand
years not all heroes wear capes British
King wears a fedora it shines in the
sunlight and reflects it just as great
as his ass don't appreciate rich kings
these days come on can you make [ __ ]
hell it is [ __ ] made out of [ __ ]
sticks come on
[Music]
we did it press I'm proud I'm proud of
you and I'm proud of everyone I want to
thank my mother and I want to thank my
father I don't want to thank Ankur
I don't want to thank Maya now that was
me
I want to think you know what someone
cares leave me you mean why do we do
this life is pointless we're all gonna
die one day
look at that bridge I know what you're
thinking all those kids in that school
bus are gonna die horribly and you're
right they probably did come on you
[ __ ] come on Joe oh my god my god my
gosh it's marking night
for [ __ ] sake I'll be over but let's
piece of [ __ ] trash oh it's a huge
spider over there oh god where is it
just keep telling people I'm good at
building wrenches because I have nothing
else going on my knife oh my god it's
still going oh there we go
please accept this school bus as my
humble offering oh mighty mighty French
king
I love you might leave a like if you
enjoyed hit some kind of combo thing
I'll see you in the next one it's all
like stay awesome bros and out of rock
yeah that's why I killed the generator
because I really wanted food I thought
that would be like chicken nuggets in
there or some [ __ ]
look how [ __ ] with huge I am don't you
think I need some chicken [ __ ] now
get well my life is pointless